اعلن برنامج سكني عم تعمل مالين فوريه غير
مسترد يصل الى 150 الف ريال بالاضافه الى
دعم عيني على الوحدات السكنيه تحت الانشاء
والاعفاء من ضريبه التصرفات العقاريه وذلك
من خلال اطلاق برنامج الدعم السكني المحدث
والذي ياتي تلبيه الاحتياجات المستفيدين
بما يتناسب مع قدراتهم التمويليه المختلفه
واحتياجاتهم لتملك السكن الملائم كما يتيح
البرنامج المحدد للمستفيد برامج داعمه
وممكنه للتملك كبرنامج الرهن الميسر و
برنامج ضمنه التمويل العقاري وغيرها من
الحلول التمويليه والسكنيه
ومن الدمام ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
عبد الرحمن خليني اولا اسالك عن ابرز
التساؤلات اللي رصدتها من خلال متابعتك
لهذا الموضوع من المواطنين حول هذا الخبر
قبل قليل عن برنامج الدعم السكني المحدث
[موسيقى]
يبحث كثيرا عن الكثير من الاجوبه لكنه
يعلم عنها بعد فتره طويله وطرح احد
المغردين مثال كود البناء الذي لم يستوعبه
بعض المواطنين الا بعد اشهر من اعتماده
ايضا احد المغردين تحدث بانه هناك
مفاجاه بالنسبه للقرارات تتعلق بالاسكان
ولا يتم التمهيد للمواطنين لاستيعاب مثل
هذه القرارات ايضا من ضمن الاسئله
والتساؤلات التي طرحها المواطنين على هذه
التغريده او هذا الخبر بان صندوق التنميه
العقاري بعدما كان يقدم في السابق دعم نصف
مليون ريال الان اصبح الدعم اقل فالثقه
اصبحت يعني بعض الشيء
يعني
متزعزعه فيما يتعلق بالصندوق التنميه
العقاري الذي خافت وهجه كثيرا خلال الفتره
الماضيه بسبب وزاره الاسكان وبرامج التي
تقدمها
للمواطنين طبعا نايف فيما نعم تفضل يعني
انا ودي اسال عما يتعلق عبد الرحمن
بالارقام حول وضع الاسكان في السعوديه
اليوم وش المعلومات اللي موجوده عندك انت
ايضا
نعم نايف الجدير بالذكر بانه وزاره
الاسكان عبر موقعها الرسمي قالت بانه 62%
هي نسبه المساكن المملوكه والمشغوله باسر
السعوديه نسبه تملك السعوديين للشقق نايف
44% ونسبه الفلل 30% في المنطقه الشرقيه
على سبيل المثال هناك 167 الفله يملكها
مواطنون
و23 الفله اشقه عذرا يملكها المواطنين
فيبدو ان الاتجاه الان في المستقبل
بالنسبه للمواطنين هو للشقق والعقارات
الرخيصه بعض الشيء لا ننسى ان هناك عزوف
حاليا بحسب احد المختصين اللي تواصلت معه
قبل اللايف نايف اكد لي بان هناك سببين
لعزوف بعض المواطنين السبب الاول هو
ارتفاع الفوائد في البنوك والسبب الثاني
هو ارتفاع الاسعار بشكل جنوني خلال
السنتين الماضيتين ربما في مستقبل الايام
نجد تخفيض في اسعار العقار يعني
المواطنين بشكل اكبر في الايام المقبله
الله يسمع منك يا عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا
لك من الدمام الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصري شكرا يا عبد الرحمن